thank you for joining us America we're
glad you are here Bert follows us on
Twitter how do you calculate how long it
will take someone to pay off their debt
well Bert I use big numbers I don't use
technical calculations here number one
most people who pay off their debts that
call in here on the show like 99 percent
of them pay off everything but their
home within a couple of years the
typical time is two years and under now
some people take you know 26 months some
take 36 months but the vast majority of
the debt free screams and other people
we talk to or under two years and so the
interest rates an interest charged
during that period of time on the
typical amount of day debt is almost
irrelevant it's not much and so I don't
even figure that into it and so then
what I do is I'm just listening for I'm
using kind of a common sense big number
approach Warren Buffett says he does big
number math and I it's kind of the way I
do it here because I'm doing it in my
head I'm not using a calculator and so
is sixth-grade math but I'm just looking
at the shovel to hole ratio the shovel
is how big your income is the hole is
how much debt not counting your mortgage
that you have and so let's me give an
example someone that calls in with a
hundred and ten thousand dollar one
hundred twenty thousand dollar income
that's ten thousand dollars a month
before taxes pretty easy 120 divided by
two well right ten thousand bucks a
month before taxes they're getting home
with eighty five hundred bucks give or
take
right now they tell me making $120,000 a
year household income that they have ten
thousand dollars worth of debt now you
tell me how fast can you pay off ten
thousand dollars if you take home pays
eighty five hundred bucks
so I'm looking at the hundred and twenty
versus the ten I mean if you can't do in
three months something's wrong it's
three grand a month right thirty three
hundred bucks a month you can do it four
months max but I mean it's not you'll be
done by Christmas basically so
that's what you're looking at and that's
all okay now you take that same person
making $120,000 household income they
have $200,000 for the debt oh well I
mean 200 divided by 50 is 4 right so
$50,000 120 is that doable
yeah that's doable that's beans and rice
that's a pretty tight budget because you
got to take taxes out of that 120 and
you got to eat and do everything else
during those years but if that's a lot
of debt that's a real bad ratio in that
and so they're probably looking at four
and if they get really cranked up
they'll probably see an increase in
income during the time that they are
getting out of debt which almost
everyone does see an increase in their
income because they're working like
crazy people to get out of debt then I
can say you know pretty conservatively
that they can get out of debt in three
to four years but if they say I'm going
to be in debt 7 years and that's their
numbers I just say no that's
unacceptable you're not willing to cut
your budget deep enough and you know
lean in and do what you need to do here
you're gonna have to get cranked up
harder than that
and so that's how I do it and so it's a
shovel to hole ratio I mean if you make
$50,000 household income get $5,000
worth of debt that's one you ought to do
in a few months you make $50,000
household income you got $100,000 worth
of debt that's gonna be years again
25,000 into a hundred four times can we
do that on 50 barely so that's a hard
one it's gonna be four plus years on
that one and that's if they don't sell
something and reduce that amount you
know thirty thousand five hundred is a
car boom we just got rid of a year and
I'm gonna start selling stuff pretty
quick there in those situations and I'm
gonna start challenging them to increase
their incomes as much as I can to
shorten the period of time that they're
in the debt and that's how I do the
calculations it's really not rocket
science there's nothing here that's much
past sixth-grade math but I'm just
thinking it through with them and
challenging them to do all they can do
to win for them them being you the
listener how fast can we get you out of
debt so that you can become outrageously
generous and wealthy and outrageous ly
generous and wealthy and not
wealthy and generous and so on how fast
can we get you there because if you're
making 120 you've got no payments hun
you got some dadgum money plus you've
actually learned how to handle money in
the process instead of it disappearing
every stinkin month and that's what
you're facing hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]